[Music]  sorry I said those things you know how  much I love you don't you  [Music]  the hell are you  [Applause]  I'm a fan of yours the CEO will beat up  two prostitutes but then got acquitted  in court yesterday except I'm  transferring 20% of your cash for these  two girls I'm Khaleel the security  arrest and transferring to your wife  [Music]  account number  don't one line what take your child and  leave he won't hurt you again  mr. Chan has bankrolled your company for  years  isn't this his wife rich we try to  contact your wife again or if anything  unexpected should happen to her  this video will be sent to me  are you not least with selecting the  right or wrong  the girl who hurts me who hurt me  I could never figure it out  why did you have everyone but me  Conte our time here  why is it this but why is it spiders  whom get stuck in the wrong webs  [Music]